with the white pieces and here we go
okay just like the last game it's a
queen's pawn opening and how will magnus
react
in this tournament we've already seen
him play the dutch defense the king's
indian defense the grunfeld defense
every opening and uh now okay it's a
queen scan bit maybe the netflix show uh
inspiring the two players will we see
the queen's gambit accepted which means
black capturing this white pawn that's
just moved taking the gambited pawn but
no the gambit is declined and magnus
goes for the slav laughing meanwhile
this time not laughing about falling
asleep laughing about something else
clearly but this is known as one of the
most solid openings in chess black just
puts pawns on light squares blocks
things up and tries to stay solid so
okay right now dude has got to decide
whether to trade pawns in the center
bring his knight out push your pawn
this is a line i think we call the slow
slav
just because things will take a while to
open up later yeah i was just about to
say this i i haven't seen you playing
the real slav i think usually he goes
for there yeah it's it's a clever move
order that has actually been advocated
by um sam shankland in his chessable
course i'm not quite sure it's a slow
slav but uh um but anyway the whole
point is that you don't have to deal
with pawn takes pawn and just a nice
kind of move order trick
and magnus actually choosing
the queen developing the queen which is
a solid and white is just going for a
slightly better position
yep dude developing the queen there and
magnus reacting by pushing a pawn he's
getting ready to develop black's light
squared bishop he's just trying to
remember
yeah exactly which line to test exactly
so it's going to be like that you know
they're going to castle and develop and
some rooks to the to the same file as
the queen and uh white star square
bishop will find itself on the edge of
the board on the b2 square as white what
would your opening choice be um i have
played magnus a few times
normally informal blitz games just
friendly blitz games
and
i've tried two different strategies one
is the reti opening but he has a chapter
on how to beat magnus how to play
against him and uh there he he says more
or less like you guys that
you should play the best moves which is
easier said than done but you should
actually aim for positional advantages
kind of make big decisions where they
have three or four options on every turn
that's the only way to confuse them and
showing no fear submitting to everything
i want to do on the board but uh if they
just go all out at me just no fear going
for my king sacrificing pieces well a
few developments on this board we did
see actually a trade of pawns in the
center so we were talking about how it
was a bit of a standoff things would
just slowly open up but things open up
very quickly due to going on the attack
or trying at least against magnus and
suddenly the white queen has found
herself over on the side of the board
the black queen now developing and this
is really interesting for magnus
you have a lot of pressure down to watch
uh duda's king yeah so that's what he's
looking for ways to do this move
basically i would say after every move
if you have the time i would try and do
a quick scan of the board and blunder
check uh with kids and chess talents
basically from africa to play online
tournament hand and brain super cool
concept businesses now can reach out if
they want to join this fantastic event
we do have a couple of moves so uh
actually magnus just pushed upon so
still delaying that big decision with
the black king which he might have to
make on this turn but uh after black
just pushed upon it we saw a capture in
the center one that ivanka was
advocating and now after a trade of one
set of pawns white's knight has just
planted itself in the middle of the
board and um right now if we jump in the
big question is can you castle and okay
magnus delays it again i was gonna say
if you castle on this side the queen
side then this king is a big target
white tonight he's going to jump over
attack your queen attack this pawn as
well this looks disastrous for black
this would be disaster again for the
black king so magnus decided okay still
delaying
castling and pushing upon taking this
square away from the white knight uh
just covering it but it's so slow uh on
the rating list in classical chess a new
nosad which also magnus went to minus
went there exactly
then you know there is school fees you
know can meet some some business guy and
like with morton now with ferdinand you
know they found each other and then
third certainly sponsors him and that's
coming after this game i bet his idol is
magnus carlsen still i would say yes if
you look at all of white's pieces
they're mobilized okay uh really
interesting castling now with black all
of white's pieces are mobilized two
white rooks teaming up
the white bishops in the uh in the
middle of the board kind of with that
gays focus on both sides the white queen
nicely placed through an attack white
centralized knight they're all fantastic
i was about to say magnus his king
situation was still uh not ideal but he
has decided to castle and i think he's
banking on some tricks here he
definitely is maybe also another trick
uh in this position if white had gone
for this then possibly now he could have
captured the pawn after white's knight
is retreated there's one clear idea dude
wants to break open the line towards the
black queen push this pawn forward this
is supported by nearly all of white's
pieces right now for example if white
initiates these trades then black is
actually going to have the better pieces
black's queen now is going to firstly
maybe start threatening some checkmating
ideas maybe the black queen as well can
jump to the center attacking white's
bishop note how the white queen is
suddenly offside for example if white
captures a pawn gets greedy then we
would see a trade of rooks and black's
queen now just breaking through the
white queen not able to help out and the
reason i say ugly is because this bishop
on the first rank
could be a target for black brook
sliding across and look at this there's
a massive trap in the position if white
plays the most greedy move and plays
pawn takes pawn it looks like white's
winning a pawn attacking the black queen
with a pawn attacking with a rook as
well then suddenly
magnus would win with a queen sacrifice
and uh this is actually on the cards
right now dude that doesn't fall into
that trap the bishop was a target pawn
takes pawn would have lost on the spot
as we just saw so he brings his bishop
back to a square it cannot be targeted
but things are turning in magnus's favor
and uh the game goes on but white is
playing temporarily without the queen
and okay he does this he blocks things
up
and he's the only one with control over
the open file now many people will be
asking what's happening here because uh
he just pushed forward his protective
passport and the most amazing pawn there
is and what happens here and he's just
offered it up for grabs
i think magnus
actually kind of trusted dude's bluff on
the last turn due to push to pawn
forward attacking black's bishop i think
that pawn could have been captured
safely and uh that's just due to some
back rank tricks um actually very
similar to the ones i highlighted so
duda gave up a pawn i think magnus could
have just grabbed it but magnus said no
i trust you and now look at that black
bishop in the corner it talked about bad
pieces white's queen being a bit offside
but suddenly that black bishop it's just
a dead piece it's a block of wood and
dude is shaking his head
but he's doing okay he can just support
this white pawn he can protect it and
that is willing to come to its aid and
uh duda does put his knight on the edge
of the board with the sole purpose of
locking that light squared bishop out
and
i
like this position suddenly for duda
currently it's tying down the black
queen it's caging this black bishop in
the corner as we mentioned
but yeah magnus is going to hope that it
can be easily blockaded you can just
ignore it pretend it's not there and
suddenly white is fun there we go we saw
that trade very quickly there from
magnus and suddenly the black queen
could start threatening this isolated
white pawn in the center of the board
the one that has just recaptured
suddenly white's really weak on the dark
squares the brook jumps in instead
attacking two pawns now i've seen him
having dead lost position sometimes the
computer says plus five for the opponent
but he still looks super calm this time
no he's shaking his head and okay he
brings his bishop oh no there we go i
mean it's just expected because of the
clock because he's lost control on the
position and that's when blunders
happened they don't just occur out of
nothing uh most of the time and okay
here we see stockfish the computer
suggestions the top two moves which give
black a significant advantage
they're also the most obvious moves in
the position you can just sidestep and
capture a point magnus does this you
could have captured the other pawn as
well on the left side that would have
been strong too but uh yeah it's looking
very good for magnus right now he's a
pawn up and white's struggling to create
counter threats uh any compensation here
okay the white bishop steps back that is
a bad sign for duda
and uh okay magnus now
can he continue being greedy
if the black rook goes away from the
center though maybe white's queen can
re-centralize itself
he's relying on tricks to save this game
magnus is a pawn up and magnus is
completely dominant on the dark squares
for now that white pawn is under locking
key yeah i mean just okay magnus does
get greedy as i mentioned and now two
pawns up for black
how do you break through on the dark
squares that's the problem okay uh white
side steps with this rook huge threat in
the position white i mentioned the
background checkmate against the white
king now blacks king is the one
threatened white's rook wants to step up
to the top of the board and that would
actually end in checkmate because
white's bishop covers the only escape
square for the black king white queen's
diagonal yeah and unfortunately that was
a logical and very good the white queen
as mentioned needs to centralize herself
there we go there was actually a huge
threat as your evangel mentioned the
white queen and bishop lined up on the
same diagonal trying to sneak through to
the black king that's just been blocked
and the thing is that i kind of want to
activate the rook but that's not really
possible magnus all he needs to do bring
the black brook into the game back and
at this point oh you'll stop on the c
file and then it's over yeah you're
right pontius just and then it's just
gonna step up with the king or something
quite soon
that's i think this is uh
it's not very good for for uh
that's a very magnus move uh stepping
forward with the black king just
covering everything defending everything
but instead magnus grabs another pawn
he's actually three pawns up and
we've just seen dude resign i think we
have magnus takes the win wow
with the white pieces in game two young
christopher duda losers to world
champion magnus crelson and magnus is
now up
by one point you guys in the final